know the difference between the button  and US versus Russia  did you have you seen that article okay  so you know on U.S the button is  controlled by who president one person  he can't push the button there he needs  multiple multiple approvals in Russia  so Russia's situation is not like what'd  you say boom that's U.S that's not what  it is in Russia so that gives a little  bit of comfort to say you have to  convince three or five people whatever  the amount of people is for them to say  we agree that it's time to push the  button so I think for the world that's a  little bit worried it's good that  Russia's button to the nuclear bomb is a  lot more regulated believe it or not as  weird as it sounds than the button in  U.S